ja vielen Dank den Arsch schätze das
dass ich heute abend wieder bei 8:15 Uhr
sein kann um zu berichten was hier was
in diesem Moment in Kiew in der
Hauptstadt passiert vor einer halben
Stunde wieder sie reden Alarm und ist
das erste Mal dass wir Explosionen
relativ in der Nähe des Zentrums gehört
haben nicht zu vergleichen mit der
Dramatik die ist in Raki Film Osten der
Stadt gab wo bewiesenermaßen
Streumunition eingesetzt wurde vor
anderthalb Stunden bin ich wieder
gekommen von einem geheimen Ort wo ich
die Klitschko Brüder erneut treffen
konnte beide sehr mitgenommen teilweise
nur ein bis zwei Stunden geschlafen und
sie sagen der Angriff auf Kiew kann jede
Minute beginnen also alle rechnen hier
damit das ist so dramatisch das ist so
schlimm werden kann auch wie im Osten
der Stadt wo ein Feuerball regelrecht
durch die Stadt sich den Weg gewalzt hat
heute war ich auf der Straße unterwegs
ich war ähm ja Bunker muss ich sagen in
einem Krankenhaus Bunker wo Säuglinge
geboren wurden heute alleine 6 Babys und
wenn man das sieht diese Babys die
geboren werden in einen Krieg in einem
Land das in einem Krieg steht wo
Menschen sterben da können einem nur die
Tränen kommen und genauso ging es mir in
der Situation in einem weiteren Bunker
in der Tram wo die Menschen saßen eine
hatte einen besonders lieben Hund dabei
den ich streicheln konnte und die gesagt
hat ich bin hier seit sieben Tagen ich
weiß nicht wie lange ich noch hier bin
aber ich habe Angst weil ich gesehen
habe wie die Rakete eingeschlagen ist am
TV Turm es sieht danach aus Nena dass
das was wir hier erlebt haben in der
Hauptstadt erst der Anfang von Putin
scrollt hatten ist
Paul du bist ja schon seit Tagen da du
siehst genau was da passiert vielleicht
kannst Du noch mal überlegen wie diese
diese Situation dass man kurz davor ist
eingekesselt zu werden also wirklich
dass wir wissen dass im Norden der Stadt
stehen irgendwie ein 60 km langer Konvoi
der russischen Armee im Osten wissen wir
jetzt das mittlerweile ganz nah am
Flughafen Boris Pohl dort auch die
russischen Einheiten vorgefahren sind
ist kannst du das vielleicht noch mal
erklären wie ist das psychologisch nicht
nur für dich sondern auch für die
Menschen dort überhaupt auszuhalten dass
man weiß da kommt wirklich feindlich
gesonnene Menschen auf einen zu von
einer Armee deren Machthaber gesagt hat
die du keine existiert überhaupt nicht
die gibt's gar nicht die Leute dort gibt
es überhaupt nicht das ist kein Staat
das sind nur Leute die die irgendwie ja
irgendwas dazwischen sind und die zu uns
kommen müssen kannst du uns noch mal
noch mal sagen wie diese diese Lage ist
von den Menschen denn wir wissen ja von
den drei Millionen etwa ein Kiefer da
ist nicht die Hälfte geflogen da sind
nicht mal 20% gefunden das sind die
meisten immer noch da und warten oder
ja Julian das ist auch das für mich
überraschende muss ich sagen gestern und
auch heute habe ich vor den Supermärkten
lange Schlangen gesehen da wird
teilweise jetzt schon rationiert alles
ist nicht mehr verfügbar es gibt
logistische Probleme und wenn man mit
den Menschen spricht und ich frage sie
warum flieht ihr nicht ihr seht doch die
panzerkolonne die auf diese Stadt zu
rollt ihr hört doch von den schweren
Waffen die eingesetzt werden dort im
Osten bereits dann sagen sie guckt mich
fast ein bisschen verständnislos an und
sagen warum Putin greift uns an und ich
soll mein Land verlassen Putin greift
uns an und ich soll fliehen Putin greift
uns an und wir sollen uns ergeben dass
es genau die Stimmung die ist hier in
der Ukraine gibt und
was wir vielleicht in Deutschland nicht
so fassen können ist dieser Patriotismus
und der sehr positiv ist muss ich sagen
zumindest auf mich diesen Eindruck macht
diese Geschlossenheit im Land dass man
auch nach sieben Jahren Arbeit an dieser
Demokratie nach dem maldan nicht unter
Putins Joch will man hat Angst davor man
will es nicht man will Richtung Westen
orientiert bleiben in der ganz großen
Mehrheit und da nimmt man sogar in Kauf
dass man eingekesselt werden kann Julian
das hier nichts mehr durchkommt dass man
hier ist aber dass man in der Ukraine
bleiben kann in der Heimat
Herr Patient schon vor der Sendung zu
mir gesagt sie will auch heranza mal
gerne eine Frage stellen
wie ist denn die die Lage so insgesamt
was sagen die Ukrainer was erwarten die
was die Russen in Kiew machen werden
nicht denn die Stadt ist ja tatsächlich
so gut wie
umzingelt und Sie müssen jetzt natürlich
irgendwas machen den Blick auf die
politische Führung des militärische
Hauptquartier die
kommunikationszentralen wissen sie da
haben sie da mehr drüber erfahren
also Kiew rechnet mit einem Angriff wir
in rakiv passiert ist oder einen anderen
Städten tatsächlich hatte man gestern
bereits angekündigt und das war eine
offizielle anfühlung aus Russland dass
man das geheimdienstgebäude angreifen
würde da hat man die Menschen
aufgefordert aus dem Bereich diesen
Bereich bereits zu verlassen und man
rechnet damit dass ja genau das nämlich
passiert neben dem Fernsehturm auf die
Kommunikation angegriffen werden kann
oder angegriffen wird mich wundert er
dass das noch nicht passiert ist
vielleicht können sie mit ihrem
militärischen Hintergrund da etwas zu
sagen ob das vielleicht doch
komplizierter ist als man denkt weil ich
hätte erwartet dass Russland das schon
geschafft schaffen würde das zu tun aber
gleichzeitig stelle ich mir die Frage
überschätzen wir eventuell alle die
russische Armee und nicht nur Putin
Strategie sondern auch das was die
russische Armee wirklich will natürlich
muss man aufpassen mit den
Bildern und Videos die wir auch von
ukrainischer Seite bekommen denn die
zeigen sich natürlich im Lichte immer
auch als Sieger und
nutzen da sozusagen in ihrem Sinne auch
eine Propaganda und dennoch sieht man ja
an vielen kleineren Orten das ist ja
auch was wir häufig vergessen es geht ja
nicht ausschließlich um Kiew sondern der
Krieg wütend in rakiv in mariopol in
Odessa in vielen vielen noch kleineren
Städten der Ukraine und da sieht man
Videos wie sich ukrainische Zivilisten
vor Panzer stellen wie sie auch mit
russischen Soldaten ganz normal reden
und die Hoffnung ist dass diese Hoffnung
hat auch die politische Führung der
Ukraine dass die Soldaten Putins nicht
bereit sind bis zum Äußersten zu gehen
zumindest in den Städten und die Befehle
umzusetzen aber wahrscheinlich ist das
eher etwas illusorisches
ja ich glaube schon Herr ronsheimer also
ich rein militärisch betrachtet glaube
ich werden sie alles tun um Straßen und
Häuserkämpfe zu vermeiden
aber das ist in Kiew nicht so einfach
dann müssen sie eigentlich rein weil
dort die politische Leitung sitzt nicht
das militärische Hauptquartier die
kommunikationszentralen wenn Sie die
intakt lassen dann denken Sie vielleicht
auch weiter schon das weiß man nicht ja
aber insgesamt
schließen Sie die großen Städte
tendenziell eher ein gehen nur
nadelstichartig rein also Geheimdienst
Hauptquartier sicherlich
Polizeihauptquartier sowas sind
natürlich Ziele aber wollen natürlich so
ein abnutzungskrieg im urbanen Umfeld
vermeiden weil sie damit auch nicht
schnell Raum gewinnen der Angriff der
Russen ist ja auch langsamer geworden
also im Norden jedenfalls das staut sich
ja alles nördlich von Kiew aber im Süden
sitzt doch wieder anders aus also da
sind Sie ja Richtung Odessa unterwegs
und dann die Landverbindung Krim in den
dombas was ich so höre scheint die fast
schon etabliert Nein zu stehen
sie irgendeine Chance
sind sie irgendeine Chance
Entschuldigung für die unterbricht
irgendeine Chance auch wenn es nur eine
1-prozentige ist für die Ukraine
ja das ist jetzt die Frage also rein
militärisch gesehen
ich habe aber mit Frau Wellnitz ja eben
auch drüber gesprochen der also dass das
rein konventionelle Übergewicht der
Russen ist enorm natürlich nicht aber
städtische Gebiet eignet sich auch gut
zur Verteidigung hat aber den Nachteil
dass die Zivilbevölkerung involviert ist
von vornherein es ist ja leicht in
Städte reinzukommen der Amerikaner im
Irak z.B
Bagdad ja man war schnell drin aber das
Problem war hinterher oder die Israelis
auch in den 80er Jahren die waren sehr
schnell in Beirut aber bei uns zu
befrieden das Land unter Kontrolle zu
halten das hat ihn wahnsinnige Probleme
gemacht und wenn es den Russen nicht
gelingt möglichst schnell sage ich mal
die Entscheidung herbeizuführen wenn es
also Richtung abnutzungskrieg geht
dann ist das
ein hoher Stressfaktor für die Russen
weil ich glaube das kann er auf Dauer
nicht lange durchhalten politisch auch
weil Putin steht ziemlich unter Druck
würde ich sagen wenn man alles zusammen
nimmt an dieser Stelle würde ich gerne
Frau Mennig in die Runde reinholen Frau
meine kann es vielleicht auch eine
Taktik sogar von Herr Putin sein dass es
ihn gar nicht überrascht dass er nicht
so schnell vorankommt das ist von Anfang
an geplant hatte sofort zu gehen könnte
das auch eine Erklärung sein warum das
Vorrücken so sagen wir fast langsam
erscheint für die Stärke der russischen
Armee ich glaube wir haben uns einfach
mit dem Gedanken abgewöhnt dass wir dass
die russische Armee die fast da einer
der größten Armee in Europa ist und ich
glaube wir haben auch da sind da viel zu
tun mit der Propaganda und
Desinformation und am 24
Februar als das der Krieg dann begann
was mich persönlich überrascht hat aber
ich möchte bitte und ich bin keine
militärexpertin dass dieser Angriff an
verschiedenen Orten stattfand und wenn
man dann mit den Menschen gesprochen hat
gab es am an manchen Orten eigentlich
nicht so groß Explosionen aber halt
Tatsache wenn man die Karte dann sich
angeschaut hat das war schon sehr
überwältigend und ich glaube am ersten
Tag wollte schon wohin einfach den
Eindruck auch im Westen erzeugen wir
sind hier und wir schaffen das sehr
schnell einfach um diese Macht nach
außen zu kommunizieren und in dem Krieg
was wir jetzt der in der Ukraine erleben
vergessen wir immer das ist einer
Hybride Kriegsführung und wir haben
heutzutage mit einem Krieg das ist schon
ein präzedenzloser Kriege die aus
verschiedenen Dimensionen besteht einmal
diese militärische Dimension die zweite
Dimension das ist Cyberangriffe die
vorher stattfanden aber auch
jetzt weiterhin stattfinden und dir die
dritte Dimension das ist Propaganda und
das Information und bei der Propaganda
ich glaube wir sind Informationen was
wir unterschätzen das ist nämlich dass
die Desinformation Propaganda schaffen
die Möglichkeit einfach eine parallele
Welt zu schaffen und ist eine der
größten Herausforderungen an der wir in
unserer Zeit zu tun